this episode of real engineering is
brought to you by curiosity stream watch
over 2400 documentaries for free for 31
days a curiosity stream calm Ford / real
engineering some crazy things happened
during the Cold War dogs were put into
orbit bears were fired out of supersonic
jets and humans landed on the moon
needless to say humans were going
through a rough breakup and were really
trying to find themselves all of these
events were centered around one
technology that changed the game for
every human on this planet nuclear
energy the bombing of Nagasaki and
Hiroshima woke the world - a nuclear
future changing the political and
cultural landscape of the world forever
infecting the imaginations of people all
over the world a spawning monster
stories like godzilla in japan and
heroes like The Incredible Hulk and
spider-man in the United States people
dreamed of a future where electricity
was free while simultaneously fearing
the ever-present threat of nuclear
annihilation these fears and dreams came
together to form perhaps one of the most
interesting technologies conceived
during the Cold War nuclear-powered
planes during World War two research and
development of nuclear energy had been
focused on its weaponization but with
the wars conclusion the United States
began to seek out ways of utilizing the
power of the atom to fuel their energy
needs the Atomic Energy Commission was
created in 1946 with the express purpose
of commercializing this new technology
and just one year later the US Air Force
invested 10 million dollars into
studying the feasibility of utilizing
this energy to power their long-range
bombers in an era before in-flight
refueling and ICBMs had been perfected
the technology was appealing with just a
small amount of fuel a bomber could fly
indefinitely it would be capable of
reaching anywhere in enemy territory an
omnipotent trek to any adversary despite
the obvious dangers of combining these
two technologies the possibilities
proved too tantalizing from 1948 to 1951
the brunt of the research centered
around a means to transfer the energy
generated by nuclear fission to
propulsion
heat energy is gained through nuclear
fission when uranium is bombarded with a
neutron it absorbs that Neutron into its
nucleus which causes severe vibrations
ripping the atom apart producing heat
additional neutrons and new lighter
atoms but the some of the products that
split are lighter than the original atom
experimental proof of Einstein's
groundbreaking 1905 paper teaching the
world of the energy and mass
relationship through the equation of e
equals mc-squared
the energy released by a single uranium
fission reaction like this is tiny a 200
million electron volts but crucially
uranium produces additional neutrons
when it splits allowing for a chain
reaction to occur so for very little
input energy we get a tremendous amount
of kinetic energy as an output in the
form of heat when controlled this
reaction can give us energy to heat
water and power our steam turbines when
uncontrolled this reaction gives us the
atomic bomb experiments began here in
the Idaho national engineering and
Environment Laboratory dubbed the HTR e
standing for the heat transfer reactor
experiment
these engines sought to find the most
efficient solution for transforming this
thermal energy into thrust they
eventually came to the HTR III
consisting of two modified general
electric j-47 engines that would perform
both propulsion and cooling functions
air would be ducted from the
low-pressure compressor through the
reactor core where would gain heat and
expand this air would then passed
through the high-pressure turbine and
exhaust to provide power and thrust as
the air was needed for cooling the
engine had to be started using
traditional fuel sources allowing the
air to pass through the cool reactor
core once sufficient airflow was
achieved the reactor could then be
brought up to power the engine contained
a temperature controlled thermocouple
which fed data to a control module which
would automatically close the chemical
fuel valve as the heat of the nuclear
reactor began to be added until the
valve was completely closed the HTR III
was successfully run multiple times but
there was still
several problems to be solved perhaps
chief among these was the energy
transfer methods propensity for spewing
radioactive air out of its exhaust this
was an open or direct cycle
configuration meaning the air is
directly used to cool the reactor core
this was a simpler setup requiring no
additional pumps within the nuclear
reactor that the program managers at
General Electric preferred but resulted
in air passing through the highly
radioactive core and thus being
contaminated and subsequently exhausted
to atmosphere obviously not an ideal
situation and this program actually
spurred the creation of the very first
molten salt nuclear reactor through the
AR II or aircraft reactor experiment
this was instead a closed cycle system
where a molten uranium tetrafluoride
salt is used as a fuel while a secondary
closed loop containing molten salt with
no uranium was used as a coolant this
coolant would then pass through a liquid
to air heat exchanger to power the
turbine this would result in radically
reduced radioactivity in the exhaust but
required more plumbing to circulate the
two fluids in the two inner closed loops
and resulted in a lower efficiency as we
are introducing an additional heat
transfer step that allows more heat to
be lost to the plumbing and environment
this method was never tested with a jet
engine but this is the earliest ancestor
of the thorium reactors which are easily
the most requested topic on this channel
as a result of their potential to
provide cheap and safe nuclear energy
both research and funding for this
technology was gradually dropped had the
program developed further these molten
salt reactors likely would have gone on
to power any eventual bomber had the
power to weight issues been overcome
these power-to-weight issues were one of
the primary roadblocks facing designers
while nuclear energy can provide
extremely long lasting energy its power
output the energy provided per unit time
is not infinite nuclear reactor is like
this have maximum power settings limited
by the heat the cooling system can
transport a way before it can begin to
melt and damage the reactor and its
control mechanisms
this made it difficult to design a
reactor capable of providing enough
energy to power jet engines with enough
thrust to get the gargantuan weight of
the reactor off the ground the HTR III
is estimated to have weighed 45 metric
tons and could produce up to 35
megawatts of thermal output far too
large and heavy and short of the 50
megawatts of thermal output targeted for
a flight where the power source the HTR
III did include removable radiation
shielding consisting of a stainless
steel shell with a LED core surrounded
by water but further testing was needed
to design an assess shielding for an
aircraft to do this convair modified a
b-36 renaming it the NB 36h crusader the
b-36 was the only aircraft in the United
States arsenal capable of taking off
with a massive nuclear reactor and its
associated shielding and coolant systems
fitting it with a small 1 megawatt
reactor dubbed the a STR or aircraft
shields test reactor which was lifted
from a shielded underground vault and
mounted in the b-36 as Bombay moments
before takeoff a plane could never carry
the amount of lead needed to shield
every facet of a reactor so this plane
would test shadow shielding which would
primarily shield the crew and
instruments in the cockpit the shielding
for the reactor was achieved with water
tanks which could be filled or drained
to vary the shielding and allow the
nuclear engineers on board to assess the
minimum volume of water needed to
protect the planes crew and instruments
with a five tonne 13 centimetre lead
shield mounted between the reactor and
the crew compartment on top of this the
crew compartment was an 11th on lead and
rubber shielded removable section the
leaded glass windows were a foot thick
and a closed circuit TV system was used
to monitor the reactor the plane was
further modified with air scoops to
funnel air to the coolant system that
would trade heat with the internal
closed-loop water coolant and then
exhaust the heat to atmosphere the
Crusader made its maiden flight on
September 17th 1955 the reactor provided
no power to the engines but the plane
would make a total of 47 flights which
occurred only
remote land far from human populations
the plane was escorted at all times by a
b-fifty which contained sensors to
measure any air scattered radiation
emitted from the reactor and air coolant
system it also contained a team of
Marines ready to parachute and secure a
crash location if the need arose at this
point the United States was at the
forefront of aircraft nuclear propulsion
technology and likely could have
developed the technology fair enough to
produce a nuclear-powered plane boss for
the best it never came to fruition on
November 18th 1958 the HTR III engines
suffered a meltdown when temperature
sensors malfunctioned recording a lower
temperature and withdrawing control rods
this may have been the impetus to shake
sense into the US government to remind
them that a mobile nuclear meltdown was
simply not something they wanted to
contend with on top of all this with the
advancement of aerial refueling and
intercontinental ballistic missiles the
technology was made completely redundant
President Kennedy ultimately canceled
the program in 1961 just one month into
his presidency putting an end to the
insane idea this hysteria and fear of
aerial bombing has made humans do some
astounding evil and stupid things if
you'd like to learn more about this
gradual descent into madness that the
advent of aerial bombing fostered I
highly recommend in watching this
documentary titled the bombing war from
Guernica to Hiroshima it takes you from
the first small grenade dropped from a
plane in World War 1 all the way to the
monstrous and unnecessary bombing
campaigns that took place in Europe and
Asia in World War two it's a fascinating
insight into the minds of the civilians
that lived through those times and the
madness that gripped the military
leaders that approved them you can watch
it now for free by signing up to
curiosity stream using the code real
engineering or using the link in the
description this will give you a month
of completely free access to over 2,400
documentaries and nonfiction titles from
some of the world's best filmmakers
after that first free month you can
continue your access for just $2.99 for
watching and thank you to all my patreon
supporters if you'd like to see more
from me the links to my Instagram
Twitter discord server and subreddit air
below
[Music]